i don't know if i would qualify a
mountain dew in the same way as sprite
and seven up and where it's like
lemon lime soda you know yeah mountain
dew tastes like
what does i guess i don't know what that
flavor is you ever licked a mountain
before that's what it sounds like there
are some weird things i've licked that
sounds weird out of context is this an
older save no no no
one of the gazebos gone but like there's
still some stuff up top that say that
they're not built i thought we'd finish
that it looks like
someone tried to put a fireplace in
probably bob you know
okay uh no it was probably someone else
just being nice and and putting
giving me a fireplace it wouldn't still
be there if someone was
trying to be nice to you you know i
figured it would have been gone but
someone was trying to do something nice
for me
i would have already destroyed it by now
you could just cut a hole
why is this door not open 68 st you have
to unlock it it is
oh yeah wait it is oh no
oh no did wait did someone what happened
what happened here it looks like there's
a wall on the other side
did like some horrible wall i don't know
i don't remember what are you guys doing
uh trying to get up top so we can assess
the situation
okay uh i'll climb the rope down i won't
take the quick
yeah the rope is the way to do it that's
for sure jumper and jumper and succotash
was not the right way to do this
say that again i won't
i just i've never heard that expression
but i like it i wasn't i wasn't trying
to criticize you i was uh
i hadn't heard it either my mouth my
brain had something else in mind and my
mouth was like
nah i'm gonna go with this i'm assessing
and yeah there's a wall in the back
here that seems bad there's just a wall
how did you get over there does it say
who built the wall no
i wish but no that would be cool but no
uh yeah i can try to bash it down i
guess
i don't know isn't there just like a
holy deconstruct thing no it's not a
thing
that's not a thing
did you destroy the whole cabin
but the [ __ ]
ah guys technically bob could reload the
save i'm just throwing that out there
no no no no no no this is life now oh
man the rope's gone too
now there's really no good way to get up
here but that [ __ ]
oh god oh my god
oh man hey mark do you feel
differently about how how just
disappointed
you were when i did that to you yeah you
know
i feel i'm just gonna beat this deer out
of the ground
are you trying to take down the exterior
wall yeah inside the house
okay what happened it looked like the
save file change and there were like
two walls like there was a door wall and
then a real wall and i think the
cabin somehow got confused and it
decided that the
no door wall was the real wall and when
i destroyed that
do you remember how many logs that cabin
required
many did did we get any of the resources
back
no they're just gone yeah
that's not ideal no time for mercy if
you were upset about the gazebo you
could have just told me
i wish anything but now was where i was
can we sleep we can't sleep sleep
yeah this bar is completely maybe
because we just loaded in but yeah that
bar is like not filled at all
okay anyway listen guys we've got some
work to do now so
mark just gave us more content that's
what i'm here for
oh this is what hell is we've been
transported to a
hell island and there's no coming back
well can't wait now that we've got all
this [ __ ] gone
now we can construct a new base yeah now
we can do whatever we want to do
didn't we decide that custom builds were
probably cheaper than the we
are yeah yeah yeah they are yeah so
let's let's
yeah new beginnings let's look at this
as a pot i think
i'm gonna just build the stairs up to
here and i can remember
where the hell the stairs were custom
stairs yeah
do that we got plenty of logs so we can
make magic happen with that
i guess i can't wait to watch the clip
of your face whenever that happened i
really hope i know it exists
i watched bob's clip of him destroying
the gazebo about a hundred times
it was pretty funny oh wow all right
well glad everyone's having their fun we
got some serious work to do guys that's
what we can yeah we've got a lot of work
to do now fellers
whatever we do we're in it together boys
it's just another reason to keep going
forward you know it's like when you kick
over an ant hill
like they just start going back to
building that ant hill they don't i hope
they don't think
like you know but there we go there we
go
am i the [ __ ] for kicking over now
well
maybe there's possibly a slight gap in
these stairs you got to really
be careful when you get towards the top
of the stairs i mean it's fine it's fine
but just you know just be careful okay
all right
you're saying they don't quite ascend to
the the heavens they're
not they're white lined up right okay
cool before they went bad so if you guys
are hungry you can grab the meats on the
fire oh
there is a cap mark look out wait oh no
the top's fine oh
top's fine for some reason i fell
through oh because i was trying to walk
on stairs that wasn't built yet
i'm just an idiot oh yeah that would
that would do it it wasn't you know it
wasn't done
no it was not done do we want one more
staircase here to like
it's fine what's the life without a
little danger
huh all right so uh we have a few things
that we can do
there's that whole quote son thing that
we can worry about
you know our missing boy
why would we expend a single resource to
while the gap is
woo hey yeah i was saying the same thing
there's also
i see what you're saying there's cool
explorables that are in caves there's a
better ax
there's like weapons and stuff that we
can use to
kill more cannibals it's a lie is that
the goal of this game to just
kill the maximum amount of cannibals i
mean you did see the number of traps
that were available so i'm assuming it
has
some pretty sure they're cannibals i've
not seen them physically actually eat
the other people
yeah i guess if you want to say it that
way yes i haven't seen someone
in the act eating another human you're
right
but the number of bones is suspicious
like that's true but that still sounds
circumstantial bob is that
circumstantial am i using that term
correctly
no okay see circumstantial
right you're right this is hideous but
we can fix this in post
oh that's interesting i like the
attitude
we're running low on logs down here
we're going to have to start logging up
there we go
we still have a bit of a gap here but i
think that's okay
gaps no that'll be fine it'll be fine
gaps are for winners
sure can't wait to see how we managed to
lose these logs you know thigh
gap the gap this gap all for winners
the gap is my favorite of the gaps yeah
is the is it the same gap that you're
supposed to mind
you mind the mind again that might be
our gap yeah
is the gap you're supposed to mind like
the gooch space
no that's the thigh gap no wait that's a
different gap what goose is the spy gap
the same as the goop
can't hear you over my chainsaw jeez
yeah i didn't know we were deforesting
this area as far as we are
oh that's water i'm wet where's the
where's the
highway is there dirt
oh that's water i'm wet wait does this
hurt
[Music]
excuse me did that hurt oh get me a game
mark let me see
oh is it done look it doesn't think it
does hurt holy cat
batman oh god it does oh it does oh man
the first time i didn't do any damage
but that time did a lot of damage
oh i had armor you broke through my arm
for the first time
this gap seems to have expanded i got
hang on hang on yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
die
the gap oh i'm freezing to death oh god
dude you got so many problems that
flincher just like
everything's a problem oh it's cold oh i
got my chainsaw wounds
i'll get over it what about side stair
like you have to zig zag up this
staircase you know
yeah no i got it i got you i got what
you're saying yeah you got it okay cool
like a single
[Applause]
can someone else try this i don't seem
to be able to complete my stair
construction if i'm 100
honest okay i gotcha
oh we have a checklist of things to do
oh find
timmy set up defenses find a way into
the sinkhole
find the missing plane passengers done
done done and done
except for timmy [ __ ] back sorry oh look
that'll work
huh oh yeah maybe
we might have to hop at the last one but
that might work it's a st
it's a big it's a big finisher the last
one's a dude
oh no you can just sprint right up oh
hell yeah jump it off perfectly
see i'm a genius oh yes you are [ __ ]
mark the master craftsman okay you're
gonna who was responsible for our
downstairs base you build our upstairs
base i trust you
yeah uh you're gonna be wanting
something
that's gonna give you the not that no
ignore that uh
we don't need any more platforms we
could just build the base on the ground
up here and make it as big as you want
this could be our upstairs i thought you
wanted to like
hang over our previous base oh yeah no
wait yeah it should be like a second
story there's a little pond up here it's
like a perfectly circular round pond do
you guys know that i ran into it last
night oh that's
water that was wet i'm wet yeah
okay okay okay okay okay okay what are
you doing there master craftsman oh
just you wait it's going to be a beaut
i'm i want i'm going to be impressed
you like buttes don't you you like
buttes i love
buttes absolute beauts all right okay
because she's gonna be uh i'm on fire
ignore the pain
ignore it ignore anything for
sake of the house she is a
beaut she's about to be beautiful bam
uh bam
oh my god look at
this now uh we we only need 115
is there a way to make like arches or
gaps in the foundation i just put
two logs on and look how much it filled
in wait hang on
pause that you see what i'm talking
about
is yeah that's why i was called because
we need that that's probably fine
cancel this oh i got it
it's fine don't worry about it listen
master craftsman here
uh-huh okay all right how's this a
little better
foundation wraps around the staircase we
got some hand holds
we only need 85 logs that's a discounted
price
this is way more efficient yeah i like
that
well and so i bet if you build another
one the foundation you can extend it
with another
uh edition and the foundation this is
gonna be expandable to your dreams you
know you're never gonna
you're never gonna get enough i'm gonna
i'm gonna downstairs log sled
okay all upstairs log sled you guys got
two sleds up there
you can bob well i wasn't gonna go with
you because mark is a chainsaw so he can
harvest more
i have a chainsaw oh am i just not using
it because we have you have a chainsaw
we got the chainsaw
oh my god did you guys know how to
change that yeah no definitely
i didn't know well i can't hear you over
the sound of my chainsaw
oh if you let the log hit you in the
head
you die am i alive
do you need to be revived no i think i'm
okay
oh that smarted real bad man we're just
learning all the things
water wet log dangerous destroy house
destroy his house
my chainsaw stops working yeah well
there's a limited amount of gasoline is
the thing
come to me right now
the door's locked
okay do you see that yeah i see it what
that is i don't know what is this
that's awful did you guys hear the
noises that it makes no
no i'm coming here come come down here i
want to get in by the house
bob i unlocked this door we can lure it
into this trap
yeah let's do it when you get close to
it watch what it does
listen it's behind this bush
[Music]
oh god it gallops
oh my god
i got happy birthday well played buddy
i don't feel better than it's dead
can we chop it up what is that yeah
somebody harvested wait
what are these oh no oh god what am i
doing oh
sticky pike sticking out of it oh
mark harvest i did i did all right i'm
gonna harvest some
oh you can get more out of it oh what am
i doing
what do i harvest what did i what is
that oh what do you pull out of it
it's called it's called creepy armor
look in your inventory it's called
creepy armor and you equip it i'm
equipping it
i equipped it
oh yeah bird come back
in here and uh land on my finger oh yeah
bird you want this
that's a that's a sincere gag reflex i'm
covered in blood and i need to wash it
off to avoid infection
that walked up behind me while i was
chopping a tree
down and i almost [ __ ] out some organs
at least at least at least you know
that the birthday machine can kill it
and really why is it on the hand that i
have to look at
that's what i want to know yeah it's
really in the way oh it's right in front
of you the whole time
take off armor nothing you can do no you
just have it
you just are armored now should we just
try this corpse before we
reset this trap or should we just leave
it here nah just reset it
or it's only like one stick or something
to do it right
yeah all right i'm resetting the trap
right now i forgot i had a slingshot
what all right oh
spider monsters okay yeah did all of our
berry bushes just like have to reset
their growth or are they gone forever
uh i don't know they were just
harvestable they were regrowing
i see maybe i see bumps in the ground
i'm assuming they just need to regroup
i think i think it was just blank when
it had nothing
so hopefully they regrow is anyone
asking what we're going to do if those
things just jump over our walls one
night and i don't want to think about it
i guess don't go away don't talk we got
we got 20 logs left here
yeah i got another dozen i'll have
another dozen coming in on the sled in a
minute we got plenty we got
we got it we got it all right i'm gonna
take my sled is there a way to cross
that river with a sled you think
i don't know we haven't tried it it must
be right i'm riding it down the hill
we could build a bridge but i'd like to
if we're going to do that i'd like to
build one that we can
yeah a closable bridge yeah oh i forgot
yeah you're right we can build bridges
yeah we can we can bridge across it okay
all right all right mark well you go
back to engineering did you get across
with your
thingy no i'm building a bridge how do
we make more gas
urine or something urine yeah yeah how
much urine do you think people boiled
trying to make
gold because they're like it's yellow
i just had that thought have you how
many alchemists in like the 16th century
were sat in their sad little room just
like yes yes
okay i've put urine and a piece of a
mouse
and uh and uh and some rocks from the
alley and i will boil these and they
will become
gold and they're just sitting there just
like
basting in the smell of boiling urine
just like yes
yes this will be the one i know why we
figured it out and see if we can boil
you're gonna make gold yeah maybe yeah
we should get together and do some
videos about
uh alchemy and boiling urine for sure
yeah guys i just want to say i built a
really sweet bridge
like i saw that dude you built that like
two two quick seconds this is a cool
little
lift you like slam that together wait
maybe it doesn't have to lift up
can you just build like a wall or a door
it was almost my birthday holy [ __ ]
oh my god no don't go that way don't go
that way
no you're right wade are you rolling
longs down a mountain wade
it's more of a cliff more than likely
lost forever
you know they fall in the direction that
you cut so were you amy yeah you have
100 percent
but it was really ambitious it was an
ambitious project i undertook and i just
did uh-huh
uh-huh there seems to be a log down here
on the ground
in the middle of the camp i don't know
what that's happening what that's about
oh my god oh no oh oh my bridge
oh god
oh why am i the only one who's got any
brain cells in this operation that's why
what did i do wrong i haven't destroyed
any structure stupidly
he's got a point mark where'd your
bridge go i
dropped a tree on it it's all gone
yeah man i'm over here with my logs so
if you guys
are cool yeah
there was completely a bridge and now
there's zero percent
and now it's gone yeah engineer it again
i will help you my dude thanks man
there's a man on fire over there's two
mans on fires
over by to your left what i don't want
to look behind me
look behind you to your left there's a
man wearing a fire skirt
there was another one why are they on
fire why were they behind
me oh this bridge is i guess it's okay
i like this bridge man there's a heck of
a bridge the last bridge was like two
pieces it was very well put together uh
it's fine there's logs on the ground
everywhere because i just started
cutting trees and i guess
one happened to land on the bridge and
i'm still you know mark
they fall in the direction that you come
oh my god
i was saying that right when it happened
finally instant karma doesn't hit me
i don't need that laugh that laugh it's
a rare way to laugh but i don't need
that one
into the watermark oh my god flee
this bridge for some reason doesn't work
it's
it's mostly a bridge but it's not
completely i thought he was about to
start walking across
it did you see him for the edge of the
bridge
sometimes i forget that this is a horror
game and then it becomes a horror game
very quickly it oh horrors real good
yeah well i brought my sled of sticks
back so uh we're ready to sled whenever
you guys oh good excellent
yes no other concerns over here when you
all quit
farting around over here all right it's
a bridge it's done okay
we should probably construct some sort
of wall or locking
device yeah like can we build a bigger
door like one that's wide enough for the
sled to go through
oh that's true [ __ ] what do we have can
we build a double door
maybe is there such thing as a double
locking door
yeah like some kind of a gate type yeah
like a gate
oh wait someone's coming someone's
coming someone's coming
oh he's coming oh he's coming from there
yeah you know what this bridge really
does make it impossible for people to go
on
okay good i'm gonna we know that now
she's just we
know that now what happened to them i
don't know she's in the drink
why is no one helping me oh i didn't
know you were back here we were by the
bridge okay coming
wow take my creepy arm i'm using my
spear to try and keep him back but he
was really
man this dude takes a lot of stabs i
hear that you get better at combat
through the game he went right through
me he tried to steal my soul
oh frick okay he's gone oh
i hear more screams of the damned oh
they're in the they're in
okay so they don't know how bridges work
which thank god
yeah he's just standing there ominous
he's walking
no no they can go on the bridge but
they'll fall in the water if you bait
them off the side
you're right you're right you're right
idiots oh you
fool mark there's another one there's
another one oh jesus
hey hey whoa good morning good morning
hey but yeah yeah go go go got him in
the head
okay oh got him in the head oh my god
don't hit the trap we need the trap
that's where i think it's locked don't
go through that door
oh they're behind me oh i'm going to
lead him around i'm going to lead him
around
i'm going to unlock the far door it's
unlocked yeah i'm coming
whoa oh oh oh oh they they didn't happen
destroying our walls
[Music]
you